this is my 30th commencement my 30th
reunion at college is going to occur
next weekend and even for those of you
who are not participating in
commencement I think there is a feeling
to being here this weekend it evokes a
sense of expectation of reflection of
anticipation of hope that's what
commencements are all about and so even
if you're not here for commencement I
hope you get that feeling the excitement
that comes it's a time of celebration a
time of well-deserved praise a chance to
finally meet the parents we've heard so
much about and I'll say I'll tell you
ninety nine percent of what we heard was
good there's a desire on the part of us
who have been through something like
thirty commencements to pass along our
wisdom and our warnings and our hopes
and our fears but I know there's a
desire on the part of those of you who
are graduating to get the sitting and
the listening parts over with as quickly
as possible so I will not belabor the
point today but the joy of coming to
worship is that we have a much larger
context in which to place something like
commencement as we gather to worship God
we have an umbrella under which to
understand what's happening this weekend
in our scriptures this weekend I think
are very helpful though they're somewhat
difficult we won't try and capture the
whole story of your years here and of
our hopes for your future because we
know that the same God who carried you
through your toughest days here will go
with you wherever you're going God will
meet you on your journey out and meet
you at the next place wherever that is
but for those of us who aren't
graduating just give us a moment to gush
over you a little bit we're proud of you
we will miss you and will miss the way
you uniquely revealed to us God's
creative spirit I was talking to a
recent alumna this week and I asked her
what would you have wanted me to preach
at your commencement should I preach
about holding fast to eternal truths no
matter what the challenges
may come or should I preach about
seizing every opportunity for adventure
and for growth and for change should I
preach words of standing fast or a
boldly striding out and she said of
course both so that's what I'll try and
do today because i think our scriptures
help I think our scriptures give us a
way to imagine both imagine the faith we
hope you will grow as you leave this
place the faith you will take with you
yet the living and growing faith you
will need our song today which we sang
in that beautiful setting asked God to
be a rock a refuge a fortress in times
of fear and anxiety Jesus understands
our uncertainty facing the future and
the Bible tells us that he says to his
disciples first off don't let your heart
be troubled this will be taken care of
the old him says on Christ the solid
rock I stand all other ground is sinking
sand all images of solidity of safety of
protection and when life is uncertain in
the next step isn't clear our faith says
that God is our rock god is dependable
what it's all about God is not really
what I believe about God because I'm
imperfect I'm not there yet I'm on a
journey once solid it's what God
believes about me what solid is the love
the acceptance the embrace of God even
as my faith is chase ined and corrected
and grows the danger of seeing God is at
rock as we heard in the reading from
acts is that a rock can also become a
weapon the story of the stoning of
Stephen from acts was read today it's
easy to forget that those stoning this
young Saint were not criminals they were
not hooligan
these were up standing religious
citizens whose faith had become so
hardened then it could not stretch to
hear his preaching so the danger of
holding on to God as a rock is the
possibility that that solidity will
become so hard that it cannot change
rather first Peter says become living
stones and that's what I want to think
about for just a minute today what in
heaven's name does that mean first Peter
is a tough book what is a living stone
it says let yourselves become living
stones let yourselves be built into a
spiritual house for you and he means you
are a chosen race a royal priesthood a
holy nation God's own people in order
that you might proclaim the mighty acts
of God who called you out of darkness
and into light people who have received
mercy if there's anything looking back
and looking forward I think this passage
capture should so well because it's
about the times we received mercy and
the times looking forward and we know we
can tell other people and show other
people what that mercy looks like says
become living stones as Christ was a
living stone not a dead fortress not a
crusader castle but a living community a
solid as a rock and yet living and
changing and growing the language of
these stone comes from Isaiah 28 where
the Prophet says see I am laying in Zion
foundation stone cornerstone a tested
stone a sure foundation and we will call
that stone one who trusts will not panic
great message for graduates going out
and for all of us one who trusts will
not panic and he says I will make
justice the line the manager and
righteousness the plumb line God is our
rock our measure our line but
is never a weapon a refuge but not a
battlements Jesus is solid but not hard
Jesus says to the disciples in his
farewell you know the way to where I am
going but then st. Thomas responds Lord
we do not know where you were going how
can we know the way and I've looked at
this passage all week and I said what is
going on here and you have to look at
the words closely Jesus is saying you
know the way to where I am going Thomas
asks Lord we don't know the place where
you're going we don't know the
destination know the way Thomas
misunderstands Jesus Thomas says you we
don't know the destination to which
you're going we don't know that final
place how can we know the way and Jesus
responds by saying I and the way we're
focused on the destination and imagine
that's what faith is that's what Jesus
is that faith is a load is a place it's
a location it's a goal but Jesus is
saying to say Thomas it's the way that
matters not the destination for you goal
oriented people as you had to be to get
through a place like Yale it's hard to
imagine faith as something that isn't
also goal oriented that has a syllabus
with a grading scale and a number of
assignments that have to be done and
when you get those assignments done you
have a perfect faith but Christian faith
is not about gathering knowledge it's
not about doing anything in particular
Christian faith is not logically and
spiritually working out correct doctrine
and defending it to the end Jesus is
saying I am the way I am the path an
orthodox theologian named vladimir
Lawsky writes that any true knowledge of
god is not rooted in study or even
practice
but in our encounter with God in the
depths of our souls that may come
through study or practice but
transformation comes only when we are
emptied by our encounter with God and
open to being then filled by God God is
not something we achieve God is
something we are a part of I think a
living stone is a person transformed by
an encounter with God who comes together
with others who have had the same
experience and together they are built
not into a fortress not into a set of
doctrines but into a community that
lives in such a way that they are able
to proclaim the mighty acts of God who
called them from darkness and into light
so often I hear people say I just can't
accept organized religion first off I
say I've never seen it organized
religion but then I what I hear in that
statement is a search for a freshness
for a purity a faithful encounter with
God not soiled or spoiled by history by
institutions by the violence of beliefs
that have been turned into weapons at
its saddest organized religion is like
yesterday's apocalypse a man-made
fantasy designed to capture people's
fear but the illusion is that by leaving
an old church building and it's pipe
organ and going down the street to toads
with electric guitars we are closer to
the radical revolutionary Jesus but as
history shows today's radical experiment
is tomorrow's institution there is no
escape if you want to escape the
confines of church the only way I know
is to live as Jesus taught because if
you live simply as Jesus taught churches
won't know what to do with you not with
any goal in mind not with old or new
institutions at heart but live simply as
he taught I had jury duty last week when
I called my brother who's a trial
consultant and I said how do I get out
of jury duty and he said
be honest and clear in all your answers
and you will automatically be excused
sort of like that with church if you
follow Jesus the church won't always
know what to do with you I that's how to
find the living faith in his poem for
the time being WH Auden wrote these
wonderful words about following Jesus
says he is the way follow him through
the land of unlikeness you will see rare
beasts and have unique adventures he is
the truth seek Him in the kingdom of
anxiety he will come to a great city
that has expected your return for years
he is the life love him in the world of
the flesh and at your marriage all its
occasions shall dance for joy we sent
you out in the belief that the god we
know in Jesus Christ will find you
wherever you land up God will find you
when you meet others whose lives like
yours are not their own who feels
strangely compelled to love to forgive
and hope compelled by a strange
encounter with God and in character they
may not be able to put fully into words
but that they cannot help but live out
every day if you go looking for a
community look for that you will meet
this God when you least expect it when
you take ridiculous risks when you step
off the prescribed path strangely you
will find God the refuge the rock when
you're willing to let go of some of the
certainties you thought most
foundational strangely you will find God
the goal when you let go of trying to
acquire God and allow God to acquire you
strangely you will find the church not
where there are numbers of people or
aesthetics or perfect doctrine but where
people honestly love each other and
their neighbors for Jesus sake you'll
find them and they'll find you amen